well let's bring in Mustafa hosim a
political analyst and professor at fast
media faculty in tan he's joining us via
Skype from there thank you very much for
joining us on Al jazer um we're just
talking there about the harsh reaction
being promised initially uh Mr RI
himself was talking about Israeli
involvement do you think they will now
accept uh this claim of responsibility
by isil and if so how will they respond
harshly against isil
hello and thanks for having me well uh
to begin with nobody buys the claim that
Isis has done that in here uh but even
if this has been Isis uh it's been done
at the hands of Isis but masterminded by
the Israelis there's no doubt in here
about that and let's remember Isis and
and nosra both were given treatment at
hospitals at Israeli hospitals in the
occupied Golden Heights they were with
visited by Netanyahu then the Israelis
gave out the photos and videos of these
events um and hospitals during the war
in Syria and also um if this has been
done by them this has been masterminded
by uh the Israeli regime uh we do sorry
what what evidence do you have to say
that I mean obviously yes there were uh
I I there were fighters who were uh who
were taken injured across to uh to
Israeli territory occupied territory in
the goolan Heights during the Syrian
Civil War but it's a bit of a it's a bit
of a step from there to saying that this
was definitively an Israeli
action there are many reasons to believe
that this has not been Isis uh first of
all the kind of casualties that have
been brought up by the T blast yesterday
uh that's a very important issue because
most of those dead and injured they've
been wounded or from chest upward this
is not known tactic to Isis this is a
tactic that hirelings of the Israeli reg
have been carrying out in Iran in former
attacks uh both Isis and these local
groups of that operate for the Israeli
regime directly or indirectly uh they
they they are known to have open ties
with the Israeli regime but in the
meantime if you just take a look at of
the military field in the region as well
as the political positions of the UK
Israel and the United States in the past
one or two weeks you realize that they
were there was a tumult in threats
towards Iran and they were promising
attacks to Iran from former Israeli
Premier natal Reet who in an
unprecedented move took responsibility
for two uh terrorist attacks on Iran in
the past and calling for striking Iran
to Netanyahu who bowed a strong strike
on Iran to lindsy Graham who was
speaking to Fox News and called for uh
striking and blowing Iran off the map in
the past few days the UK has also been
uh going along the same path more or
less so they were promising it they
started with uh Razzi musavi in Syria
they went for Al aruri in Beirut and now
this uh we there is no doubt about uh
the very fact that this has been an
Israeli masterminded plot that's why the
Iranian said in his message that those
uh corrupt hands if I'm not mistaken in
the translation that have uh shed the
blood of innocent people as well as
those that have masterminded the corrupt
masterminded that had done this to us
will be the target of attacks and the
the the the tumult of attacks starts
right now I just want to um just just to
to push back I wanted two things there I
I haven't seen any British government
official saying that Iran should be
erased from the map and U certainly the
Israeli attacks that have been either
claimed or have not been denied by
Israel in the past have been different
they've been targeting uh Iran Iranian
nuclear scientists or or facilities but
let's leave to that to one side I guess
the important thing now is what the
Iranians say and how they respond uh
what they believe has happened and what
the response might be in terms of the
broader escalation that we're currently
witnessing in the region where do you
think it goes from
here um I didn't say that the British
said they they need to strike Iran off
the map I said they threatened Iran
alongside Israel and the us and it was
Congressman lindsy Graham in the US
actually who's known to have anti-iran
positions he said it during a recent uh
Fox news interview in the past 3 days
that Iran should come under attack and
should and he said the United States
should blow it off the map that that
means Iran of course so that that was
what he said I thought you said the the
British were going along with that but
but anyway let's move on to the idea of
where Iran responds and how it
responds yeah Iran has multiple options
open let's remember that according to
the Israeli media when they assassinated
Dr fak in Iran 3 four months later uh
the the father of their Aerospace
military Aerospace program abar ABI har
even was killed at the heart of Israel
in AER uh the hotel that he was residing
and several other Israeli top officials
were there uh was set to fire by mot of
cocktails that's what they said that
they blame Iran after they carried out
sabotage attacks at Nan facility two of
their military I mean and ballistic
missile manufacture uring plants uh
blasted also when they targeted Iranian
ships their ships went on fire and so on
so for uh when they attacked Iran
through cyber space they said that they
Reed the stronger responses including uh
what New York Times says quoting the
Israeli American cyber security firm
checkpoint that Iran has grown so
powerful and sophisticated in cyber
space that uh around the same time that
October 7 attack started uh they claimed
that much uh you know information and
Intel of shabbach shin mad and and the
military part of the Israeli
arm I'm sorry I'm going to have to
interrupt understood there are multiple
options and it is done things you say in
the past at a timing of its choosing I
appreciate your uh your analysis see and
and your patience for with with some
technical problems we've been having to
to get you on the air appreciate it
thank you very much thank you thank you
very